hello what you want to we are the lake
town spy network are you Kafka quickly
go tell the master of Laketown that the
hobbit panel is about began suits boy
run hello
if I can only go back in time and show
this to my 13 year old self welcome
today's panel on Hobbit battle of five
armies and a celebration of Peter
Jackson's movement alert the battle for
six movies my name is Stephen Colbert
and if you are anything like me you
don't just love these stories you
treasure the world of junior our token
let me take you to a time long ago an
earlier age the time of Clinton's the
dark days dial-up internet a rumor came
to us that director Peter Jackson will
be making an adaptation of the trilogy
at the time any of us knew him only from
his movie heavenly creatures and as
great as that movie is I wasn't sure
there's room for hysterical murderous
teenage girls in middle-earth other than
of course elin I was worried that
somehow we would take away my treasure
my horde of precious middle-earth
stories it was a very possessive
obsessive ferry tragedy feeling so I
found and followed everything I could
about the progress of these movies I've
ever seen the first stills from the
filming of Helm's Deep I looked at every
casting announcement I scoured the work
of John how on a lowly I read the online
debates about fantasy versus fairy tales
and I began to have hope not just hope
the movies would be good I was going to
hope that finally finally people when I
roll their eyes and I started talking
about middle-earth that my head full of
facts from the North a rumor
they have some social value that someone
might say we hey Stephen you know a lot
about colgan you can't explain something
to me and I would say yes oh god yes I
will
and then the movies broke upon the world
and a steal a line from CS Lewis here
were beauties that Pierce like swords
are burned like cold iron here were
movies that would break your heart good
beyond hope and rather than taking away
our treasure peter and fran walsh
philippa boyens and richard taylor and
grant nature and dan hannah and the cast
and the crew and when a digital and the
land and the people of New Zealand
itself added to our stories complimented
our imagination the only problem as I
saw it was that a total running time of
11 and a half hours they were too damn
short
you see this must be our land Oh bloom
feels all we wanted more and that we had
to wait nearly a decade our patience was
rewarded with the cast and creative team
we love and trust and we were invited
back to Hobbiton to Rivendell across the
Misty Mountains cold or through water
wood and he'll buy read and Willow to
finally come face to face with a
beautiful but dangerous silver tongue
villain of the hobbit the lake that's
why I just hope I fulfilled professor
tokens vision
well welcome welcome I have a cast heard
I have a question to start off for
everyone on stage right now do you get
that everywhere you go with this
relation or just everywhere in San Diego
Peter how are you hey yes I'm very good
thank you saving thank you very much for
coming hold on behalf on behalf of
myself and everyone here and all the
fans around the world or glass how many
years now since for a movie came out 13
yeah thank you something like that yeah
thank you very much for making these
ninjas you're very welcome thank you I
do have to see the apologies from
Madison and Ian and Richard you would
all love to be even Matlin Richard on
stage in London and I'm able to get away
no yeah and shooting a baby that's right
yes as what's happening something yes
but they do silly love and I'm sure
you'll see them again sometime some of
the magic soap you are you done for the
last book yet no no we're still working
on where listen I think the creation of
a baby never really stops and so what we
are doing at the moment I mean it's
anything but it's a lot more than
anything because we because we are wrong
we've got battle sequences to do a lot
of other rather intricate things and so
we're doing motion capture for that or
we're doing animation you know in the
case of some of the big creatures and
and we are and so I'm supervising that
in that goes on to the motion-capture
stage then I go on with a virtual camera
and I film it which I absolutely love
doing so I'm still shooting the movie in
essence they haven't stopped me filming
in it hey anyone in Bailey loop you
big battle I think we have six thousand
extras who my people to die I know they
would be good to the plane babe I want
to do well they said if I thought that
the movies are made as you said you're
doing a lot of this motion captured
going into the digital environment for
the camera captured things hmm the
people who work together on stage and
this is the first time some of you have
met here at comic-con even though you've
done the movie together yes yes have any
whoever made scenes together and never
met before yes okay we work together
neither nikkei too well after i finished
one he was pretty used to be my
renovation wow did either of you
complain that he other personal stealing
focus yeah she's just a trailer and give
it that big momma I kept eating snacks
and I was a new white all this idea it's
kind of amazing Peter when you started
back in nineteen was nineteen
ninety-five when you first start about
doing these movies yeah 95 or 96
sometime like that so by the time this
film is relief once it's released and so
they'll still be running in nineteen in
2015 you will spend 20 years thinking
about this world to imagine that this
was going to take a generation of your
life
well it's a commitment is no really it's
a good at that but no I its equipment i
really have really enjoyed taking it's
for that do you never know what's going
to happen next i mean the very first
thing that we ever pitched summer max
back in 95 wasn't for zone to make the
hobbit as a single movie and if it was
successful we do to go to the Rings
movies that was the pitch that was what
we were sort of things were a bit
differently good name but yes a week was
originally history two months yeah well
the hobbit was going to be we were going
to shoot the hub at first as one movie
and then of that was successful we do
normal the Rings back to back to movies
and there was a [ __ ] to merrimack so
that was the oceans and so I yeah and it
was so good everything's it just changes
as organic so he does not put me would
be really boring it was 20 years where
you hit it all laid out music what was
going to happen and you just took the
boxes but as soon as they've been show
every stickers in an engine I don't want
to complain to you again as I have
before that since the hobbit which is
one book became three movies technically
you always six more movies for the
trilogy should warmers can find a way to
do that they will face simply be very
happy
I'm Elijah yes sir hello y know that
you're you doing this this is amazing it
is time I realize that why why don't you
age did you know you were casting the
immortal maybe have a painting in my
attic that's agent for me it kind of
goes the same thing else it goes for the
elves I mean for land oh and hey it's I
don't know what creams are putting down
on you I want some that's a good idea we
should come up with what you made the
hell with ice cream I do as a fan you
have a question for the elves people
play those in the movie so um sin cells
are immortal all the elves we like it
you let me know distinguish between
people who play those of you who are
else you might be an elf they do it else
do you ever think differently or you
think as a human you have to put
yourself in the mind of it immortal when
you do this do pity on the rest of your
cash members different therapists ID
cuff yes they're incredibly generous I'm
obvious rightfully get a job in this one
I thought my time was our own little SUV
but our elders generous to me or have
Peter been generous to bring you back
what do you mean I think idea but okay I
do i do you think the legend was
incredibly jealous it was a big stretch
for me the trilogy of The Hobbit was
announced my understanding is that the
tone of the movies are sort of
progressed for the tone of lord of the
rings movies are sort of match up when
you watch them all together how would
you say the tone has changed from the
first movie from an unexpected journey
to desolation small house that extended
this movie well it's I mean I think it's
extended the way that you would imagine
it would extend seeing the first two
it's it's a progression and it's
certainly young I got on so everybody in
this room knows what's gonna happen
latina logo big one yeah there are there
are the set of sadness and tragedy and
which is good it's always great when you
can kill colossal main characters I'll
tell you what this maker think God
people ugly you can finally killed
somebody a chance to do something you
know it's about a little emotional and I
was you a little bit I mean it's so
anyway we we we do get to collision you
than this time round so it's good and I
think you'll skills you'll feel it
getting quite be able I mean that dark
isn't the word i mean it is i mean these
are fun movies funny I mean I'm original
fun identity it is yeah I understood yes
it's not as conco as the first of a
movie for sure lauren and rigidly
getting towards the time of the finish
including generalize was 18 years old
[ __ ] male noises which one I worked it
out and he's still 18 years old fell
apart as one of the screenwriters when
having the luxury of telling the story
over three movies instead of one do you
wish you had been able to include more
things in the first two movies minute in
the first three movies if you had this
sort of pace of storytelling you have in
The Hobbit as opposed to lord the rings
are the things that you guys wish you
could put in the first three movies you
had to take out just for time yeah you
mean motive the right yeah short sight
when I take a Liberty anguish yeah what
yeah of course the on Flores easily and
Tom I did you think about Tom Bombadil
at all to consider but we did we have it
with
I use including am seeing his head well
they were on the road doing that we
actually wrote that into the script um
but know that we have to be for another
generation of filmmakers I suspect the
gentleman in mind for the cast for
Bombadil no can I tell you that we did
do it that wish list I remember and it's
sitting a lot some because Pete keeps
everything and our net wish list was a
young Australian actress burglar girl
called cate blanchett that was our
absolute value on young know this is
true ok all right ok delicious box on
there was our first at first list of
possible people well better you're
playing the ultimate heavy okay you
playing ultimate heavies in this mode
like you're lying souring and you're
playing the drag on you how would you
how would you how would you characterize
the difference between these two bad
guys once dragon
sounded you need to know this once
dragon and once an old sing none
corporal entity of evil yes so get ready
then no one's great I'm night wait in
once great once made of something that's
vulnerable in what seems two people went
out of everything that's evil and
difficult to pin down to actually kill
is ready is there any you have benefit
to do the motion capture that you had an
experienced before as an actor is it
something that motion capture gives you
okay with Madame a country to just make
a complete fool of yourself and lose
yourself in your imagination or not you
don't have to hit mum it's much harder
these guys over green screen acting
opposite ping-pong balls and marks at
tape and pretending that's a reality in
the whole costume with continuity taken
into account cameras I was just throwing
myself around the carpeted floor like a
lunatic and and if you have the advice
for him did did what was the theory
advice for Benedict on how to do most
just make sure lea like a carpet burns
really gentle developer in the right
place it exactly met a very quick thank
you hi Graham as Dwalin yes I swollen do
you think that the dwarves get enough
credit in this movie for mental heroes
because they're not the most obviously
sexy creatures well obviously to the
female towards we're very very sexy are
they there are but I I've often thought
the entire journey is seeking a female
dwarf while it takes us a long time but
um no it's it's nice to be the only
representative of my race here today I
feel a little outnumbered by my elven
compat rates but ya know it's been it's
been an extraordinary experience being
known being a dwarf when you 643 let
alone that alone was two and a half
years I'll never forget look can you
actually shoot a bow did you know how to
do that before you took the job um yes
yes yeah I heard you learn we will Boy
Scouts oh no no did it in budgets no one
know what that is
very working-class holiday result that I
went with my family his kids and also we
used to do is actually but no I mean
when we got to when i got to the student
i really did it properly then and he's
very very big boy there was much bigger
than me and arrows that were very very
much and yeah i could probably do it we
did have a question to a day to shame
because i think Aidan Turner remembers
that they were we were all shooting
because the dwarves used to shoot from
the hip I used to shoot from the face
one and we had to a man these their
action measurement Warren um hi and I
did it I got it a beating kate is an elf
we haven't had a chance to see you fight
that's one of the things that the elves
do better than anyone else there are the
ninjas of middle earth are we going to
be able to see you fight this time do
you have weapon well I actually have not
been the high school production of The
Hobbit which he actually played the bad
so I was prepared for a bit of fighting
but as an elf you have to work very tall
I'm relatively door panel that will add
to it is hugely kaiserdisco glen boo boo
so it's a little bit tricky to even walk
so underneath that gown you guysyou
amazon you've got just feels on under
the gown no bake just a height we knew
we don't get the seagull Ariel losing it
a little bit of a snitch may be good
yeah elven [ __ ]
I'm sure sparkles
instakicks everyone's a little and this
nature center filpo have you recovered
from me smoking you in the Tolkien
trivia contest in august of 2010 and he
stopped therapy for me crushing you know
i was i was very touching because you're
very beautiful wife came up afterwards
and said i think this is the greatest
night of his life contest with Philippa
and hates everyone and I want any was
and I said I said to you you don't
understand I was I'm oh I'm an athlete
who's been training since either life or
race he never knew was coming a little
closer than you remember that we could
rebound the challenge for charity they
remember what what you want on what was
the winning answer D remember no but I
do remember when stephen fry said oh
you've really got the crowd on your side
that's when you asked me who cold Barry
was oh yeah yeah actually asked me what
color Barry was not who Goldberg was
today I think yeah he was charged with
me up a silver dollar range yeah it was
me and Steven and we were asking each
other questions so I think nobody else
in the room you were than we were
getting them right or wrong it was in
the final round was Stephen Fry and I
designed cushions for the two of you to
start with and ending you guys ended up
just clinic when you in a little bit
crazy being you guys to start firing
really hard ones at each other and we
know none of us really knew clear that's
right for me was on US legal Barry and
my head down on the table and everyone
thought I didn't know what the answer
was but I was just trying to think the
first line of the poem so I raised my
head says of slender is a willow wand Oh
clearer than Clearwater daughter Oh
springtime and summertime and the leaves
left
they call it is normally winners a very
modest something I never have this
opportunity again now I noticed that
there is a difference in in class in el
mundo and Orlando your father does not
want you to date down prep to you could
address this is there socialism is their
social message in this movie yes I'm a
low-class elf is that what you won't be
your trash trash my [ __ ] still sparkles
who's that on your resume that have you
got the gig we've heard by generations
we like risen up um well Peter I think
based on the time I think maybe we've
from a world where a time where a
television mm okay we've broken the
right of 55 minutes so ultimate
submissions all right if you run into
issues any of the actors here any of the
actors here i'd like to ask about your
experience in New Zealand you know Lee
Francis had you been to New Zealand
before
I never been before but I absolutely
made the most of it I love being outside
and I kid stuff and you can't find a
better place for that and he's doing
like awesome awesome pipes really really
fun I had a feeling when I wouldn't went
down there and get Peter invited sound
very kindly my wife and my two boys and
I were extras and we spent two weeks
down there I had a strong feeling I
should never leave New Zealand man
really calls she was as if your hearty
was raw as this mountain is did you
carve out a life plus no bears so did we
have you go to anybody when the
adventure travel down there because
there's a lot of ways to kill yourself
not being killed by an animal in New
Zealand and it may take advantage when I
decided I went up my wife i went in
there me I can save yourself because
without a contract but I did like this
year while I was down there you tell me
I'll just after the middle of the Fox
case here and then left the state for a
few hours really how we work to ice
caves yeah I don't know they mean they
didn't jump out of an airplane is all
that junk jumps out things jumped off
they may never get thrown out of awful
energy did you move down there for any
period of time like three years after
the movie was over did I understood you
said you stay stay for a while I was not
coming on a bit so it's funny actually
because that was an email exchange to me
and Dawn and Elijah just two days ago
talking about a residency in New Zealand
doesn't play we will start applying for
my son he sending me the anchovies are
here yeah only only throws himself off
anything and with a bungee honest like
I'm unbelievable then any do you come to
the stories of
Lord of the Rings and on for the first
time through the films and did it make
you then go back to the books or you say
to hell with that I'm never gonna read
them Eliza's you go back and read the
books I actually haven't truth be told I
still haven't listened I said this
before Elijah do you know how to read I
a child I read when I was a child and it
was a big book for me and I had the lord
of the rings on my shelf and it was one
of those things that was very daunting
and it's kind of always there and i
thought i'll get to that one day and
then these movies came out and I sort of
felt like I was living in an experienced
it in such a profoundly deep way that I
never really consulted the books i
mentioned something i will go back to
but i don't know such an experience over
the course of such a long period of time
I I loved reading Lord of the Rings so
much when I was young that when I got
about 25 pages to the end a fraternity
king I take my book and I remember they
closed it like that I will never beat
those pages is this story by school
never read post beautiful ever oh oh
then I'm Angelina no serious cake is
serious talking game no no no I love
love love love token but I don't know
squat like I can't remember the names
the places so I fail every joking he
tests don't try but I love him oh he's
so disappointed
I just wanted it all actually you never
been more attractive what do you think
of my hair should I keep this fantastic